[Music]
a pensive prime minister his body
language says it all at a vaccine center
today in his uxbridge constituency but
unable to shake away now mountain
accusations the latest in an email from
his private sector back in the spring of
2020 inviting staff to a garden party to
celebrate hard work
it read hi all after what has been an
incredibly busy period we thought it
would be nice to make the most of this
lovely weather and have some socially
distanced drinks in the number 10 garden
this evening please join us from 6pm and
bring your own booze martin
no comment from the prime minister did
you and carrie attend the downing street
party that was organized by martin
reynolds on the 20th of may all
all of that as you know is the subject
of a a proper uh investigation by sue
gray so have you already been
interviewed by sue gray and if not do
you object to her questioning you again
about this uh all that subject for an
interview for a investigation by sue
grey
sue grey is the senior civil servant
conducting an investigation into a
number of alleged parties in number 10
and whitehall during lockdowns
this also being looked at another
gathering in the downing street garden
on may 15 2020 with the pm and this man
martin reynolds who just days after this
photo was taken
invited staff to the garden for drinks
again the opposition say this pm's not
fit for office i think it should go to
the met police and that they should
they should deal with it if the law has
been broken boris johnson is not above
the law he should be dealt with through
the law but his mp should deal with him
as well he's not fit to be prime
minister if he believes he can break his
rules and lie to the british public he's
not fit to hold that office do you think
he should resign i think he should go i
mean there's no no excuses and it would
come as no surprise that i don't think
boris johnson is up for the job but more
importantly i think he's lost the
confidence of the british public now
with his lies his deceit and his
breaking of his own rules
may 2020 was a month with record
temperatures that people wanted to enjoy
but the rules were clear and spelled out
publicly by this minister at a downing
street press conference the very day
staff gathered privately in the garden
you can spend time outdoors and exercise
as often as you like and you can meet
one person outside your household in an
outdoor public place provided that you
stay two meters apart
say in one thing in public doing another
in private i'm told by one eyewitness
that there are around 40 people that
gathered in the downing street garden
including the prime minister and his
wife on may the 20th now at the time the
rules were clear we were in lockdown and
you could only meet with one person
outside to socialize
a downing street figure has told me
tonight that there was unease amongst
some staff over this proposed gathering
and the red flag was raised but it went
ahead anyway
what really happened behind that door
will be revealed soon when the
investigation concludes but the danger
for this pm is that many voters and some
of his own mps have already made up
their minds beth rigby sky news
westminster
and beth joins me now live from downing
streets what might beth appear to be a
deliberate attempt to shift the blame
but the question still coming back for
the prime minister boris johnson
yes and this is a prime minister under
real pressure tonight anna i was looking
back to some of the remarks he'd made
about parties
before christmas on december the 8th he
told the commons
that he had been assured
that there were no parties and no covert
rules were broken that's what he said he
was repeatedly assured by his civil
servants i spoke to him a few days after
that where he told me explicitly i
haven't broken any rules and yet tonight
we find out that there was a gathering
in the number 10 garden where it was
bring your own
bottle well if that's not a party i'm
not sure what is and that the prime
minister was in attendance so you look
back at what he said and what he did and
it just doesn't add up now where are we
in terms of the blame game and also that
investigation well there is pressure on
martin reynolds tonight some people
saying this is the
prime minister's uh principal private
secretary he's one of his civil servants
who help him in his office some people
putting the blame onto him saying why
did he put this email out but one former
cabinet minister made the point to me
tonight well he does what the prime
minister asked him to do and did he do
that off his own bat or did the prime
minister somehow know
this was happening now that
investigation is running along sue gray
will
give her verdict soon but as for the
parliamentary party i have to say i
spoke to one senior conservative mp
tonight mps have been in the commons for
votes this evening saying there is a lot
of deep unhappiness in the party at the
moment and as one mp said to me at some
point this prime minister really is
going to run out of road
beth rugby live there in downing street
for us thank you well that story is
featuring tomorrow's newspapers here
then is the metro the headline downing
it street we'll have our extended press
preview and